[Music]
please
what's going on reject nation we uh greg
and john here
what's going on reject nation this is
i'm not used to doing it when was when
we're both here yeah i know you got it
man you got this
john i believe in you anyway how's it
going guys we have a
report here circling
there are reports circling around that
marvel has a plan for a new disney plus
series centered around the character of
wolverine and
i love wolverine i love wolverine too
but i'll only accept
one person in the room uh and naturally
with any wolverine story there are also
rumors about who might be reprising the
role or who might be taking up the
mantle for the first time
compiled a few different sources here
but there's some pretty interesting
developments
about this and if they are true it's
pretty exciting so
uh the first part of this story comes
from that hashtag show.com we're gonna
be dealing with all the most reputable
sources today but
but they've broken some things in the
past and their report here says we can
exclusively share
that marvel is in the early development
on a series for disney plus
this series would be an anthology based
on the character of wolverine they go on
to say wolverine's an immortal and has a
multitude of stories to tell each season
will focus on a particular story within
the wolverine mythos like american
horror story where there's a season-long
plot and then it resets only in this
you'll have the center of wolverine
which seems
like a pretty exciting concept to me no
you don't like that
i thought it would be like each episode
would be like a different point in his
life but so they would want to do like
seasons of television with the wolverine
character
have it be like american horror story
where it's like one specific
chapter or era basically that montage
that we saw in x-men origins wolverine
yes but excited
but instead of a montage of the season
for one of those clips
that's what i'm gathering here yeah and
i mean honestly when i first read this i
read it as oh it's gonna be a different
one every episode which got me excited
but the american horror story approach i
think
works as well when you think of just how
many like graphic novels comprised of
many issues there like there's so many
wolverine stories that i get where
they're coming from with that
i guess it depends on how many episodes
per season they'd want to do
absolutely 25 25 25.
i'm like maybe you only need like five
episodes a season if this is what you're
doing it'd be cool to watch him go from
how he got his powers to like would
there be a season dedicated to before he
even got adamantium and then
you would go into old man logan by the
end like there's a version of this that
sounds awesome it's like it's just a
major commitment dude hold on to your
hat because uh they've got at least a
couple rumored story details uh really
like what oh dude well marvel and kevin
feige have been like what hard
oh sorry weapons man weapon x they've
been hard at work on an approach to the
mutants and x-men characters and uh the
sources
their sources are saying basically that
wolverine has been one of the hardest
characters uh for them to kind of
process into the new world because of
the host of stories they are to tell and
he says marvel uh studios and kevin
feige are confident that an anthology
series can safely explore wolverine's
vast history
without affecting any role that he would
have in any other x-men
film so you know mobility but basically
they they went on to say that while in
early in development marvel is aiming to
adapt the famous weapon x
story arc for the first season basically
getting into the whole origin of
wolverine the experiments the adamantium
and all that stuff
boring so i think what you gotta do is
your first season should just be logan
logan no wolverine and discovering his
powers it's gotta be like a slow burn
yeah it's gotta be like first season
iron fist like where is this going can
you hurry up and get to the point we
know he's going to be wolverine
yeah absolutely that would be the way to
he's not even called logan yet he's just
howling
he's just james yeah it's jimmy
it's gotta be like a better call saul
slover yeah yeah
yeah yeah so buy like a from james
watch that would be i would be there for
this oh we would be in here
mostly i would watch that slow burn all
day
and then it's an end with him like
getting involved with a william striker
weapon x
though i don't think is it william
stryker in the comics my memory is not
serving me correctly
yeah not at least in the refresher i was
doing earlier today
not in the weapon x uh comics anyhow
there are some other stories that
they've said they were interested in
adapting namely uh marvel studios is
from geekocity
uh president kevin feige enjoyed
wolverine's pirate adventures as
patch in madrapore and those may be
adapted
in one of the upcoming wolverine
properties which i mean they've just
introduced match report in falcon of the
winter soldier from what i understand
this is not among the most
beloved wolverine portrayals however
that sounds like fun and that
kind of appeals to the sort of wacky
variety i keep hoping they'll kind of
embrace
with all this multi-version yeah i want
charlotte copley to play wolverine oh my
god that's a great
call he could do all this weird
wackiness yeah dude slip in and out of
it all think of him in hardcore henry
but if he just looked like the character
from elysium and there you go
yeah and the patch series has more of
like an indiana jones meets casablanca
kind of uh
swashbuckling vibe also we you know
obviously can't talk about
wolverine without talking about casting
and the rumor is right now
at least that hugh jackman wants to see
scripts for whatever they're planning
so that he can you know really decide if
he wants to give the roll up or not
you know they've been talked about uh
deadpool 3 and doctor strange 2
for his appearances or whatever but it
seems like they're also not ruling out
the possibility that he could just
reprise the role entirely and i mean
he's been trepidatious about that some
of these articles go on to say that his
main worry
is that wolverine died in logan and
resurrecting him from his mortal coil
would cheapen
uh james mangold's masterpiece and then
it says apparently
kevin feige has reassured him that this
wasn't the same wolverine
instead he would be a logan from a
multiverse
and that the continuity would be
different which i mean
in a technical way i feel like would
solve a problem but i feel like
just with audience uh association it's
still kind of
gonna intertwine with logan and kind of
mess with that
it depends it depends i think a lot will
have to come down to aesthetic because i
get
where you're going with that where it
could work though is we
we usually saw hugh jackman as wolverine
with a very specific look until logan
where he
was all grayed out super old so it was
crazy
yeah yeah so i'm saying if you go back
to the like
the younger version of logo like hugh
jackman ages gracefully
so like if you if you go back to how we
looked
say in like x-men days of future past
with that style like the traditional
wolverine look yeah yeah i think we
could buy it that he's from a different
universe yeah it would look weird if it
was old man logan again
yeah that that's when it would i think
it would not really
work but you know if they like mess it
up it could put a little stank in it
if they mess it up because think about
what happened ralph boner
that's not quicksilver that's not uh
peter maximoff that's not him
now whenever i see quicksilver in the
x-men movies even if i watch the clip my
mind goes to ralph boner now yeah and
like what this role will eventually turn
into in the association now
and how they botched it so yeah i think
that could be the worry
is like if they botched this but i don't
think they would do that
if you're going to successfully be able
to get hugh jackman back as wolverine
messed that up yeah i mean if it's good
enough to get him on board in the first
place and then you know once you've got
him yeah you're going to make that
project as good as you can
you're gonna pour your time and
resources into trying to assure that at
very least but uh there's also been some
rumors beyond hugh jackman
i honestly don't exactly expect him to
come back for anything more than
deadpool 3.
um but anyway there have been rumors
circulating that carl urban
is one of the actors being considered by
marvel studios to take on the role of
james howard aka logan aka wolverine in
the mcu
goes on to state that the studio's first
choice for the role is taryn edgerton
but it looks like they might not be able
to get him
uh and because of that carl urban is one
of their top choices obviously carl
urban has already been scourged in thor
ragnarok but he died you know who cares
he can he can take up the role i think
carl i think it just too big of
a yeah i think skirt he wasn't like the
main character but i think he was one of
the faces of thor ragnarok yeah he was
one of the surprise
you know uh surprising breakout
characters that was a lot more fun and
memorable than you would have thought
whereas with like civil war you had the
character actors who plays mariah and
luke cage but
no one even knows the the character's
name in civil war yeah
yeah absolutely and so and this is like
the movie franchises we're talking
even still like they're connected this
is mcu this would be too
i i don't think they would get carl
urban yeah i mean it would be kind of
a distraction and also roles he would be
perfect although at the same time i feel
like the roles we see him play
especially now and especially in the age
of billy butcher
i know he could do it and it's like it
would be fun to see
but i wouldn't exactly be like oh man i
wonder what he's gonna do
you know yeah yeah especially with
wolverine's become it's like it's fun
when you watch like a hugh jackman
interview you're like this guy's a total
broadway
theater yeah super nice yeah yeah
energetically vulnerable expressive
emotional guy
yeah he plays wolverine which is like
bravado and seriously closed off
rage yeah i mean carl urban's fun
too but uh and and funny enough everyone
plays so many of these guys yes
yeah that's true and funny enough the uh
anthony starr who plays homelander on
the boys has also expressed his interest
in perhaps taking up the role
which i think could be cool but charltoe
copley man nothing beats that character
that's the one that i want yeah and i
think too if
if hugh jackman isn't deadpool 3 i think
he's going to play hugh jackman
i think that'll make a bit out of like
we were supposed to we won a wolverine
this whole time i don't think he was
just huge i don't think he would reprise
his wolverine roll for it i'm pretty
sure he would just be deadpool through
might just be hugh jackman my hope is
that he's just hugh jackman in deadpool
3
but he is wolverine in multiverse for
just like
one of those like you know days of
future past style cameos or not uh one
of those first-class style cameos thank
god you corrected yourself
no doubt no and then apocalypse they do
the the the the the origin story and
then the x
yeah the x-wing the x-wing this is task
force
x x gonna give it to you ballistic x
versus sever
x-men united weapon x wrap this up we're
ready to wrap this up guys
who do you think should play wolverine
are you excited about the possibility of
an anthology series leave us your
thoughts
and as always remember to like subscribe
hit that notification bell for whenever
the next video's out
love you guys check us out on patreon